madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal arrivée à lyon cet après midi
des premiers réfugiés venant de
macédoine 2 autre avion devrait atterrir
dans la soirée au total 307 albanais
prise en charge d'abord par du foyer
d'accueil en macédoine et en albanie le
flot des réfugiés continue de prendre de
l'ampleur 35 mille nouveaux arrivants
sont attendus dans les jours qui
viennent à la frontière avec l'albanie
après la démission de philippe sega les
ténors de la droite appelle à une liste
d'union et tendre la main au centre
françois bayrou fait ce soir une réponse
en demi teinte
jean pierre chevènement donnent le coup
d'envoi de la réforme de la police
parisienne avec pour objectif une police
de proximité et d'accueil
et puis du cinéma avec la sortie
mercredi prochain du film de chris
menges de l'asean signe qui dénonce les
réseaux depuis de sylvie daniel auteuil
et joue le rôle d'un détective privé
c'est la première fois qu'ils en anglais
d'aller lé auteuil est l'invité de ce
journal good evening ouvrons cette
édition avec l'arrivée cet après midi à
lyon d'un premier groupe de réfugiés
venant de macédoine deux autres vols
militaires devraient dans les heures qui
viennent
permettre à quelques trois cent sept
personnes au total de trouver en france
une terre d'accueil
ces familles composées en partie
d'enfants en bas âge seront dans un
premier temps répartis dans des foyers
est la margot olivier robert le premier
avion s'est posé avec plus de deux
heures de retard
certains l'attendaient depuis 8 heures
ce matin pour voir arriver leurs parents
ou amis
parmi les 149 premiers réfugiés
officiellement accueilli par la france
des familles beaucoup d'enfants et déjà
la nostalgie de leur pays
triste arrivé pour beaucoup qui guettait
leurs proches sans trop poser riz croire
il faudra attendre l'avion suivant
dans le terminal qui leur a été
spécialement affectés
les réfugiés se repose du voyage mais
aussi des trois éprouvant deux semaines
qui viennent du niveau de plusieurs
milliers sont stressés ils ont vu
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de la
violence au kosovo pudeur la violence en
macédoine aussi
même garde espoir de rentrer valent bien
sûr ça c'est notre plus grand espoir et
on espère qu'en rentrant rentrer au
kosovo les plus vite la plus vite
possible
un geste d'amitié pour accompagner
l'inévitable déracinement 90 bénévoles
de la croix rouge ont offert un repas et
des vêtements réfugiés et surtout un peu
de réconfort
il ya sur place les équipiers
secouristes qui ont été formés et
sensibilisés au soutien psychologique
pour avoir l'attitude juste délicate
les avis de personnes en souffrance
psychique mais déjà il faut repartir
les huit centres d'hébergement de lyon
seront leurs premiers toi après des
semaines passées dans les camps
macédonien certains d'entre eux ont de
la famille en donc le temps qu'on mette
les deux familles ensemble ça prend
quelques jours et puis si certains ne
retrouvent pas leur famille kosovare en
france et bien les familles françaises
qui seront proposés qui sont autour dans
la région de lyon viendront les voir on
s'est rappelé m pour les réfugiés le
plus dur ne sera sans doute pas
d'oublier les souffrances des dernières
semaines
leur crainte c'est de devoir se résigner
à oublier leur pays
selon des critères simples le pré 6 et
albanais chassé du kosovo ont trouvé
refuge en france depuis ce matin les
derniers préparatifs sur place en
macédoine pour ce nouvel exil où se
mêlent le soulagement et le désespoir de
l'éloignement
valérie fournier ou frédéric basket la
séparation tout cruel que l'exil pour
ces kosovars d'habitude si fiers si
digne n'exprimant jamais aucune plainte
sur leur sort mais il s'agit de
l'éclatement d'une famille qui met en
colère le consul de france
alors il faut gâcher mais maintenant on
fait quoi je suis pas content il
réussira à les faire monter dans le
premier avion des modifications de
dernière minute pour réunir des kosovars
qui ont un sens très large de la famille
pour 307 personnes très dur et se sont
séparé mais formule par exemple les
familles sont séparées il parle en fait
de la famille de son frère
d'autres vivent cette séparation comme
la dispersion d'une nation aujourd'hui
disséminés dans les pays de l'est je
suis content pour ma famille moi je suis
content vraiment content je suis triste
jeunesse mes compatriotes encore ici je
sais pas cela se passait a vécu non
content de parler en français
parmi les premiers à partir vers la
france ceux qui ont aidé les militaires
français et les organisations
humanitaires dans leur tâche ils ont
joué un rôle crucial dans le
fonctionnement du camp
c'est bien plus du travail sadien
patients obligatoirement vous êtes
obligé de d'achat des gens seuls 307
réfugient sur les mille volontaires ont
été sélectionnés par la france un
accueil modéré dans la droite ligne de
la position française
tout le monde s'est rallié à cette
politique du maintien au maximum des
réfugiés près de leurs terres les
familles qui veulent quitter ce camp
pour une situation temporaire et venir
chez nous pour le faire
d'autres départs sont prévus la semaine
prochaine peut être seront ils mieux
organiser les vols d'aujourd'hui ont
beaucoup de retard ce retard est dû à la
lenteur administrative des organisations
humanitaires chargé ici d'enregistrer le
départ de chaque réfugié
résultat le deuxième avion vers la
france n'est parti qu'en fin d'après
midi
il reste encore 100 personnes à évacuer
sur seulement 300 sec et précisément en
direct de l'aéroport de lyon satolas
virginie fichiers savez-vous d'abord à
quel moment vont atterrir donc ces deux
prochains avion transportant se réfugier
bien on attend ce deuxième avion d'ici
une dizaine de minutes environ il s'agit
d'un transall avec une soixantaine
d'hommes à son bord quant au troisième
et bien on ne l'attend que vers 23h30 à
la suite effectivement de retards
successifs dans les rotations
au total il faut savoir que ce soir à
lyon ce sont 3 148 personnes qui seront
hébergés au lieu des 307 annoncé
initialement
alors on l'a dit ces réfugiés seront
d'abord prise en charge par des centres
d'hébergement mais par la suite certains
d'entre eux pourraient comme le disait
bernard kouchner gagner des familles
d'accueil vous confirmer bien coûter
pour le moment c'est vrai qu'ici les
priorités sont ailleurs il faut d'abord
éviter absolument de séparer les membres
d'une même famille qui sont souvent
nombreux et il faut leur offrir une
vraie tranquillité certains n'ont pas
dormi dans un lit depuis cinq ou six
semaines
alors c'est vrai aussi que bernard
kouchner s'est voulu catégorique il
souhaite absolument que les foyers soit
une solution transitoire que d'ici un
mois
nombre de ces réfugiés puissent trouver
un toit
chez les familles d'accueil qui se sont
portés volontaires pour les accueillir
mais le ministre est également conscient
qu'il aura un long travail de
préparation psychologique à faire des
deux côtés et puis il faut déjà penser
aux prochains arrivants
on les attend normalement dès mardi à
paris ils seront peut-être 500 merci
bien gêné en albanie au poste frontière
de maureen al aoussat chef pour beaucoup
la route de l'exil les forces serbes ont
tiré la nuit dernière un obus de mortier
et non loin de là une mine a explosé
faisant plusieurs victimes
le malheur s'ajoute au malheur alors que
le flot des réfugiés prend une nouvelle
ampleur à ne penser méfie du jasmin il y
avait un tel embouteillage s'est tenue à
la frontière qu'un policier serbe a fait
reculer cette voiture blanche sur une
mine
cinq personnes sont mortes dans
l'explosion deux adultes et trois
enfants seul le corps de la grand mère
de la famille disait ce matin sous une
tente
côté albanais ils ne nous ont pas
autorisés à prendre tous les corps parce
que c'était monnaies les ars vont qu'un
dessert de nous laver ni avant et
comment aurait-il pu savoir que les
albanais du kosovo terrés dans leurs
villages depuis des semaines aucune télé
ne leur a montré ces images des forces
serbes en train de creuser le sol à
l'endroit précis où la voiture a sauté
dans la matinée la carcasse a été poussé
et le flot des réfugiés a repris 4200
personnes jusqu'à 14 heures avec selon
certaines informations une files
d'attentes de 17 km soit 34 mille autres
réfugiés
leurs propos sont sans surprise il
affirme que ce sont les serbes qui les
pousse ici et le départ d un provoque
des réactions en chaîne
les serbes sont venus chez nos voisins
en voyant ça on a décidé partie 90
conscient de la ville de puteaux vague
d'incendiés il ya même des gens brûlés
la cadence est telle qu'il est difficile
eu l'air charles et l'arrivée de ces
réfugiés dont beaucoup de citadins en
voiture ce actions les rues de coupe
caisse avec ses infrastructures déjà
chaotique la préfecture tente tant bien
que mal de faire face aux besoins
élémentaires de l'homme actuellement
nous sommes obligés pris l'eau dans la
ville de temps en temps ils vont pouvoir
redistribuer dans les différents camps
ce que nous avons partagé nos le pain et
la douleur avec les kosovars confrontés
à la pénurie cook s installe les
réfugiés pour un provisoire qui risque
de durer
on construit tout ce temps de 6000
personnes cherchent ni une canalisation
de 4,8 secondes
jusqu'à présent le ravitaillement se
fait par camion citerne à certaines
heures kukes ressemble à un immense camp
de réfugiés avec des distributions à
tous les coins de rue combien de temps
la ville et les réfugiés supportera-t-il
cela
direct de concasseurs nalbandyan pensée
n'est rien donc pour cette seule journée
près de 5000 albanais ont franchi la
frontière d'après certaines estimations
ce sont donc 35 mille nouveaux réfugiés
qui sont attendus dans les jours qui
viennent et l'albanie ne veut plus
porter le poids de cet exode massif
c'est donc une situation inextricable
oui puisque la ville de cook et s'essaye
peu à peu d'évacuer ces réfugiés 50 cars
ont quitté la ville ce matin mais le
problème se pose d'ailleurs et les
réfugiés le savent ils ont entendu dire
que les voitures sans plaques en
provenance du kosovo n'arrive plus à
rentrer dans tirana
alors il se demande où on va les envoyer
il préfère encore rester ici un albanais
nous disait récemment souvenez vous de
ces images les albanais qui tentait de
par bateaux entiers de traverser la mer
en direction de l'italie et l'europe
l'italie avait pris peur à l'époque
avait parlé déferlement et cet homme
nous disait à l'époque il s'agissait de
quelques dizaines de milliers d'albanais
pour des millions d'italiens
aujourd'hui nous les albanais déséthyl
nous recevons des centaines de milliers
de personnes alors que nous ne sommes
que quelques millions et c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont besoin d'aidé lorsqu il parle
lorsqu'il parle d' aide
ils demandent une aide lourde en ce qui
concerne l'eau par exemple il ne suffit
plus seulement d'apporter des bouteilles
d'eau mais bien des tuyaux pour refaire
des canalisations temps les
infrastructures de son pays de ce pays
sauts sont défaillantes
mersen consignes et ces derniers jours
les témoignages des exactions commises
par les serbes se multiplient hervé
brusini finit plus de dix ans rencontré
dans un des camps de macédoine
cette jeune femme de 21 ans qui a été
violée par des serbes appartenant à la
milice ou moment où elle quittait la
ville de pristina en blanc fille criait
l'aîné elle est venue accompagner sa
soeur pessah 21 ans deux jeunes femmes
du kosovo réfugiée dans ce camp de
stankovic tenus par les militaires
français en serbie à pristina le 1er
avril les neuf personnes de leurs
familles étaient sommés de sortir de
chez elle un ultimatum que 15 minutes
lancé par mégaphone dans la rue toute la
famille rejoint les habitants de la
capitale du kosovo qui se déplace dans
longue colonne un premier barrage des
policiers arrêtent les deux frères de la
famille
ils exigent 5000 marque pour les libérer
le père qui n'a pas cette somme de bande
à la foule de lui prêter l'argent
finalement les serbes se résigne
à libérer tout le monde mais déjà un
second barrage stoppe la marche des neuf
personnes et aussi nous ont demandé de
l'argent ils ont pensé que ma soeur on
avait cachée sur elle alors ils l'ont
emmené pour la contrôler un des
policiers m'a dit viens ici toi tu
caches de l'argent mon père a dit non
elle narnia j'ai regardé mon père dans
les yeux et je lui ai demandé mais
qu'est ce que je fais vas-y m'at-il dit
si c'est juste un contrôle et au liberia
après c'était dans le garage d'une
maison
nous y sommes entrés il a crié sur
l'argent que tu caches
j'ai répondu que je n'avais rien j'ai
dit qu'on avait déjà tout donné au
premier barrage qu'on leur avait donné
300 dinars après trois autres policiers
sont arrivés et ils m'ont violée
ça a duré une heure après ils m'ont
relâché
c'était des gens qui avaient le visage
masqué
oui c'était masqué est ce qui lui a
semblé que ses hommes étaient dans un
état anormal et ce qu'ils avaient l'air
très excité drogués non non en fait je
ne sais pas ici j'ai vu un médecin
français
il m'a examiné et il m'a dit on va faire
une analyse doit tester concert avec le
docteur time to suis allé faire une
échographie à l'hôpital du scorff
est ce qu'elle pense que ce qui lui est
arrivé a pu arriver aussi à beaucoup
d'autres femmes là-bas au kosovo oui je
le pense
j'ai su que c'était déjà arrivé à
beaucoup de femmes
et puis elles sont reparties avec le
jeune médecin français qui les a prises
en charge lui seul partage le secret de
cette blessure que le reste de la
famille ignore ces dernières 24 heures
les opérations militaires de l'otan sont
montées en puissance de nombreuses
explosions après stinat au kosovo
plusieurs usines touchées dans les
environs de belgrade dont l'une pourrait
être à l'origine d'une sévère pollution
pour la population le point avec sa
corne et l'aviation de l'otan a mené
depuis les dernières 24 heures plus de
500 missions aériennes et les frappent
les plus intenses depuis le début des
bombardements sur la yougoslavie de 24
mars
les bombes et les missiles ont touché
une nouvelle fois ce complexe
pétrochimique de pancevo à 15 km au
nord-est de belgrade provocante and
gigantesque incendie
la raffinerie deux usines pétrochimiques
et des unités de production d'ammoniac
et d'engrais azotés n'aurait été que
partiellement détruits selon belgrade
mais l'énorme nuage toxique poussé par
le vent pourrait entraîner des risques
d'intoxication les autorités médicales
ont recommandé aux habitants de la
région de se protéger les yeux et les
voies respiratoires
pendant ce temps le dispositif militaire
d'hugo slave au kosovo comme nous le
montre aujourd'hui la télévision de
belgrade campe sur ses positions
défensives et attend de pied ferme
selon le commandant de la troisième
armée les soldats de l'otan
ces unités de la troisième armée
yougoslave au kosovo sel est prête à 150
mille hommes prévenez nous sommes prêts
dit le général à la guerre totale que
l'agresseur ne sous-estiment pas notre
détermination et les capacités de notre
armée alors que l'épuration ethnique se
poursuite au kosovo poussant ces
réfugiés vers l'albanie
l'otan affirme toujours exclure une
invasion terrestre ce n'est pas l'avis
du journal dominical britannique sunday
observeur qui annonce que l'otan se
prépare à déclencher une opération
terrestre au kosovo dans les six à huit
semaines
avec 280 mille soldats aujourd'hui dans
une interview à la bbc le secrétaire
général de l'otan pour la première fois
n'excluait pas totalement cette
hypothèse
à l'heure actuelle nous pensons que
l'intervention aérienne est suffisante
les autorités militaires qui organise
cette intervention estime qu'elle est
suffisant nous n'allons pas changer de
stratégie maintenant mais si cette
invasion terrestre s avère nécessaire je
suis persuadé que les pays de l'otan
seront prêts à la mettre en oeuvre
en attendant les porte parole de l'otan
continuent à dénoncer les atrocités
commises au kosovo par les serbes
aujourd'hui le général marani affirmé
que l'alliance détenait des photos
aériennes qui prouve l'existence aux
courses aux veaux de 43 fosses communes
il a ajouté que les civils kosovars
étaient contraints par les forces serbes
de creuser ces fausses ou des tombes
individuelles
déjà hier l'otan nous avait montré cette
photo à gauche un terrain vierge que
nous voyons et à droite sur ce même
cliché des tombes aligner fraîchement
creusée
nous retrouvons maintenant à belgrade
jacques merlino il a traversé une partie
de la yougoslavie la nuit dernière sous
les bombardements
voici ce qu'il a pu constater et bien
écoutez la première chose que j'ai pu
constater hier un avis ça qui est une
grande ville au nord de belgrade donc
près de la hongrie est la grande
vivacité des défenses aériennes la
première alerte est déclenchée vers 22
heures
peu après on pouvait entendre les bruits
des avions qui se rapprochaient de leur
objectif une grande raffinerie à côté de
la ville est aussitôt l'adc à ces mises
à tirer
et cela a duré près d'une heure et demie
on pouvait localiser une quinzaine de
départs comme si toute la ville était
entouré de défense anti aérienne et
d'après les sons on se rendait bien
compte que des armes très différentes et
est utilisé et que en tout cas on ne
cherchait pas à économiser les munitions
c'est relativement une surprise après
trois semaines de bombardements de
l'otan cela prouve en tout cas pour
cette région que la maîtrise du ciel
n'est pas encore acquise
et cela confirme le sentiment que ce
conflit sera beaucoup plus long que
prévu au monténégro maintenant dans
cette république qui fait partie de la
fédération yougoslave mais qui chaque
jour un peu plus prend ses distances
avec belgrade
les hommes sont susceptibles d'être
mobilisées pour se battre aux côtés de
l'armée serbe contre les forces de
l'alliance ces jours-ci certains
ministres y compris le vice président
ont reçu leurs ordres de mobilisation
qu'ils ont décidé d'ignorer reportage de
nos envoyés spéciaux
maryse burgot gilles jacquier
et ils en sont fiers pendant des heures
ils sont capables de parler de leur
attachement viscéral à leur république
où elles se battront les armes à la main
pour elle mais sûrement pas pour la
yougoslavie à laquelle le monténégro et
pourtant rattacher la plupart de ces
mêmes reçu des ordres de mobilisation de
l'armée yougoslave slobodan milosevic
veut absolument que les monténégrins à y
combattre pour lui contre les temps mais
personne ici n'a accepté de l'eau sur
moi je ne veux pas y aller à l'armée
cette armée ce n'est pas la mienne c'est
une armée d'occupation et monténégro
n'est pas en guerre c'est la serbie qui
est en guerre contre le monde entier
nous qu'il n'y a aucune raison que nous
combattions
c'est donc en chantant qu'ils refusent
les ordres de monsieur milosevic à c'est
signé les hommes se sont organisés en
comités de résistance pour empêcher les
fédéraux d'emmener de force ceux qui
sont en âge de combattre
et ils ne sont pas les seuls des
élevages ou canaux beach ministre de
l'industrie du monténégro lui aussi a
reçu l'ordre de mobilisation
un morceau de papier données de belgrade
qu'il ne respecte pas j'ai beaucoup ri
congelés reçu parce que je sais que cela
vient d'un gouvernement fédéral illégal
que le monténégro ne reconnaît rien pour
moi ce n'est pas sérieux
alors les autorités monténégrines
s'organise voici le vice premier
ministre li est constamment escortés par
quatre gardes du corps
il faut empêcher que les fédéraux ne le
traduit en cour martiale pour avoir
ouvertement critiqué les ordres de
mobilisation au bureau de crise nous
avons constaté qu'en serbie
la mobilisation est moins importante en
fait ils font ça ici au monténégro repas
réalisé savoir si des abus par un
monsieur qui lie barda continue donc à
assumer ses fonctions
n'en déplaise à slobodan milosevic
malgré cette réduction d'une partie de
la population civile 25000 monténégrins
ont accepté ces trois dernières semaines
d'être réserviste pour l'armée de
slobodan milosevic
cela montre bien que la république est
aujourd'hui dangereusement divisée entre
d'une part les partisans du leader serbe
et d'autre part les fidèles du pouvoir
en place
et puis 12 membres de l'ue ces cas qui
auraient cherché refuge au monténégro
ont été arrêtés vendredi dernier c'est
du moins ce qu'indique la presse
aujourd'hui en france l'effort de
solidarité se poursuit en fin de matinée
à convoi d'une quinzaine de camions
transportant des vivres à quitter la
région parisienne à destination de
marseille pour être ensuite acheminés
ces vivres
l'albanie en macédoine le président de
la croix-rouge internationale avait fait
exprès le déplacement auparavant il
s'était entretenu avec jacques chirac se
disant extrêmement satisfaits du plein
appui de la france christophe kulikowska
bruno niver tous les camions de l'espoir
sont partis 15 semi remorques affrété
par la croix rouge française 300 tonnes
de vivres destinés aux réfugiés du
kosovo
mais avant leur départ le président
suisse du comité international de la
croix rouge était en visite sur le
terrain cornelio sommaruga admirative de
l'élan de solidarité des français 1
million de colis dix mille tonnes de
vivres récolté dix mille tonnes qui
devraient être acheminés dans les camps
de réfugiés
mais le problème pour la croix rouge
aujourd'hui c'est l'axé même au kosovo
un accès toujours refusée par les serbes
mais cornelio sommaruga ne désespère pas
de convaincre le président milosevic
tout la barge devoudelle lui parler je
voudrais le rencontrer lui fait savoir
déjà depuis dix jours j'ai eu l'occasion
de le rencontrer dans le passé je
voudrais régler ça à son niveau
pour l'instant vous n'arrivez pas à le
voir je n'ai pas encore lu il a refusé
non vous allez le voir j'espère
en attendant 300 tonnes de vivres
doivent être acheminés les chauffeurs
tous bénévoles participent aussi à cette
chaîne de solidarité
et ce n'est pas la première fois
j'allais faire fait il ya dix ans un
convoi sur l'arménie
l'année d'après pour la roumanie après
al encore pour les kurdes dans que
schalke invités
destination de ces camions un entrepôt
marseillais de la croix-rouge de là
rapidement les colis par avion ou par
bateau arriveront dans les nombreux
camps de réfugiés albanais oumma ces
données les ministres européens des
finances réunis hier en allemagne ont
commencé a estimé le coût de cette
guerre en yougoslavie sur le plan
militaire bien sûr mais aussi sur le
plan humanitaire au total l'aide
d'urgence aux réfugiés s'élèverait à
environ 780 millions d'euros soit plus
de 5 milliards de francs
pascal golomer quelles aides pour le
kosovo et surtout quels financements les
15 ministres de l'union européenne ont
fait le point sur ces questions ce
week-end à 13 et 15 qui ont à ce jour
débloquer plus de 5 milliards de francs
la france par exemple chiffres son aide
pour les réfugiés kosovars à 225
millions de francs
75 millions de francs pour l'accueil des
réfugiés en france et 295 millions de
francs pour sa participation à l'aide
européenne soit au total 600 millions de
francs
la france qui propose d'accorder un
moratoire de deux ans à la macédoine et
l'albanie pour le remboursement de leur
dette
coût 1 milliard de francs pour
l'ensemble des créanciers européens ou
non
quant aux dépenses purement militaire la
france les évalue pour elle seule entre
250 et 300 millions de francs par mois
sans compter les munitions sa
contribution au budget de l'otan 450
millions de francs n'a pas été revu à la
hausse
le temps très évasif aujourd'hui sur le
montant de ses propres dépenses
la situation est compliquée parce que
chaque paye bien sûr finance ces propos
opérations et clay fixe repro des coûts
en commun de l'alliance mais je dois
dire que et ils sont plutôt modeste par
rapport à ce que des pays de l'alliance
finances sur le plan national
aux etats-unis par exemple le pentagone
par la voix de son porte parole a
confirmé hier qu'il demanderait au
congrès une rallonge budgétaire de 6
milliards de dollars 36 milliards de
francs 3 milliards de francs pour l'aide
humanitaire
33 milliards de francs pour les
opérations militaires
faut-il craindre enfin l'impact négatif
de la crise des balkans sur l'économie
mondiale les indices boursiers à new
york comme à paris sont à la hausse
depuis les premières frappes voilà la
réponse des marchés financiers quant à
la serbie bombardée depuis trois
semaines aucun expert n'a osé pour
l'instant chiffrer le coût de la
reconstruction
la crise au kosovo et à l'évidence au
coeur de la politique française et les
verts réunis en congrès ont finalement
voté une motion affirmant que
l'intervention militaire au kosovo
devait être soutenue il aura fallu tout
le talent de persuasion de dominique
voynet de daniel cohn bendit pour faire
accepter ce qui pour certains militants
étaient inacceptables
alban nicosie jean-pierre pasteur 64
voix pour 22 contre et voilà les verts
qui affichent leur mutation
ils soutiennent officiellement la
poursuite des bombardements de l'otan
décision symbolique après deux jours de
débats passionnés dans la salle et dans
les couloirs alors dominique voynet a dû
user de toute son autorité et de la
solidarité gouvernementale pour
convaincre des délégués historiquement
sceptiques
aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas les verts qui
ont changé c'est la situation qui est
différente
ni va-t-en guerre ni munichois nous
savons que quelles que soient les
réserves de chacun sur l'action armée en
cours
son interruption signifierait à l'heure
actuelle une victoire de la dictature de
milosevic
dominique voynet qui a aussi estimé
qu'une intervention terrestre sera
pratiquement inévitables position réfuté
publiquement par la députée marie hélène
aubert qui s'est démarqué des positions
adoptées par la direction du parti et
moi ça me gêne énormément que des verts
ils sont les seuls à le faire même nos
gouvernements ne le propose pas même
fisher ne propose pas propre aux eu une
intervention terrestre
il faut pas se cacher derrière les mots
quoi qu'il arrive je ne comprends pas
que des verts proposent cela l'électorat
des verts selon les sondages est
cependant prêt à un engagement terrestre
une perspective qui réjouit daniel cohn
bendit
d'aller plus loin et appelle la france à
accueillir tous les soldats serbes qui
voudraient déserté nos jours après la
démission surprise de philippe sega les
grands ténors de la droite se sont
exprimés dans différents médias toute
cette fin de journée
edouard balladur que nicolas sarkozy
appelle à une liste d'union de
l'opposition on attendait la réponse de
françois bayrou
elle n'est venue qu'en demi-teinte chez
wittamer nicolas sarkozy veut que les
choses aillent vite
privé de tête de liste avec le départ de
philippe séguin le rpr et démocratie
libérale devront avoir réglé la question
dans la semaine qui vivent ce soir le
président par intérim du mouvement
gaulliste réitère sa proposition à l'udf
il faut dit-il une liste unique il ya
80% des électeurs de l'opposition qui
veulent une liste d'union
je considère que le devoir des
responsables politiques c'est de se
comporter en responsable de faire preuve
de bon sens
d'écouter la voix populaire qui nous dit
vous êtes d'accord sur le fond unissez
vous alain madelin est à l'unisson
jusqu'à présent numéro deux de la
principale liste d'opposition
il lança françois bayrou le même appel
puisqu'il y avait affiché il le fait que
c'était philippe seguin obstacles
l'obstacle n'est plus là et les
circonstances aujourd'hui à mes yeux
commandes de cette union la plus large
de l'opposition donc peut-être que
enfin l'offre publique d'union que nous
avons lancé depuis le début va être
entendu c'est donc de sa réponse à lui
que dépendra la formule retenue
finalement par la droite aux élections
européennes
ce soir françois bayrou est prêt à
rebattre les cartes mais ils posent des
conditions draconiennes pour se rasseoir
à la table
sarkozy madelin bayrou et pour faire la
belote à 3 je ne suis pas intéressé si
nous avons une vision commune et s'ils
sont capables de le dire et de sortir
des faux semblants dans lesquels on
était et s'ils sont capables de surcroît
le faire en sorte que on se respecte
à l'intérieur de l'opposition alors je
suis partisan de l'ouverture et du
rassemblement
en manoeuvre est petit réconciliation en
perspective un exercice que l'on a déjà
pratiqué la droite doit trouver une
porte de sortie
et puis pour sa part sans le pascoe a
estimé qu'avec le départ de philippe
séguin à la garantie golis n'existe plus
jugeant que l'intérim assuré par nicolas
sarkozy n'était pas bon ainsi donc ce
soir chacun s'est exprimé l'udf est
sorti de son silence
mais pour autant on n'est pas beaucoup
plus avancé car il n'y a pas eu de
réponse à cette main tendue gérard le
cam à écouter absolument le suspense
reste entier d'un côté le rpr en pleine
épreuve fait un véritable forcing son
président par intérim nicolas sarkozy en
appelle de façon solennelle et presque
pathétique à la responsabilité et au bon
sens de l'udf avec trois arguments chocs
1 l'union répond à l'attenté pressante
des électeurs de l'opposition 78% selon
le sondage du jour 2 rpr udf partagent
les choix et la politique européenne de
jacques chirac
et puis 3 les responsables des deux
formations déjà gouvernement sentent
donc comment ne pourrait-il pas faire
liste commune
alors vous l'avez dit en réponse
françois bayrou sans fermer la porte
mais les enchères vraiment très haut
certes il entend la demande d' union du
peuple de droite ils la souhaitent
mais surtout pas à n'importe quel prix
et au nom de la clarté et de la
cohérence ce sera au prix fort pour le
rpr françois bayrou réclame un accord
sur un projet fédéraliste englobant une
défense européenne
une constitution européenne voir un
président européen président d'europe
autant d'idées qui font frémir nombre de
gaulliste et puis histoire d'enfoncer le
clou et de montrer qu'il n'a rien oublié
des humiliations passé le présent du df
barthel qu'il rejettera toute union
bidons les tripatouillages les mensonges
banale hier p r aimablement qualifie au
passage de champ de ruines alors en
résumé ces unions il doit y avoir elles
sauront elle sera aux conditions de
l'udf tant pis et les gaullistes doivent
manger leur chapeau et cela prendra un
peu de temps quand le rpr voulait régler
la faire dans les trois ou quatre jours
l'union est un combat disette ont
autrefois à gauche aujourd'hui à droite
c'est une bataille sans merci et l'issue
encore incertaine
merci gérard et puis ce sondage la
démission de philippe séguin est une
bonne chose pour la gauche selon 51%
défendre les français sondage à paraître
demain dans le parisien
c'est aujourd'hui que jean pierre
chevènement a lancé sa grande réforme de
la police parisienne avec pour objectif
de donner aux citoyens une police de
limité et d'accueil le détail de ce
réaménagement des forces de police dans
la capitale
joël bruandet français depuis 6h30 ce
matin les parisiens disposent d'une
nouvelle police la police urbaine de
proximité une réforme engagée par jean
pierre chevènement en 1997 et qui
aboutit aujourd'hui à la création d'un
corps de douze mille agents ses
fonctionnaires le ministre de
l'intérieur leur a confié une mission
être à la fois plus présent sur la voie
publique est plus proche des habitants
elles vont les parisiens ils n'auront
plus à courir d'un commissariat à
l'autre un ils seront que ils ont une
chaîne des commissariats qui les reçoit
qui est disponible en permanence et qui
traitent leurs affaires en temps réel
désormais en effet chaque arrondissement
dispose d'un commissariat
ouvert 24 heures sur 24 et où l'on peut
venir déposer plainte à tout moment pour
obtenir ce résultat il a fallu
réorganiser l'ensemble des effectifs de
la préfecture de police
on a ainsi procédé à près de 14000
mutation mais mutation ne signifie pas
création de poste et certains syndicats
de police en sont tout à fait conscients
je suis très satisfait quand mettre en
place la police urbaine de proximité
c'est un très très bel outil pour nos
parisienne nos concitoyens la population
seulement il faudrait admettre aussi les
hommes en place c'est-à-dire il
manquerait appris avec surprise
plus de mille gardien le bureau annie
pour jean pierre chevènement il faudra
un peu de temps avant que cette réforme
donne des résultats notamment en matière
de lutte contre la petite délinquance le
ministre de l'intérieur souhaite en tout
cas que la réforme de la police
nationale soit terminée à l'horizon 2001
près de l'aéroport d'ajaccio plusieurs
charges explosives ont touché deux
bâtiments dans l'enceinte militaire d'un
camp de l'armée de l'air
un commando du flnc canal historique
s'est introduit dans cette base a
neutralisé les gardiens et installer les
charges à londres maintenant l'explosion
qui s'est produite hier en fin de
journée devant un supermarché à une
heure de grande affluence a fait au
total 48 blessés 23 personnes sont
encore hospitalisées
toujours pas de revendication la bombe
de fabrication très artisanal indique
aux enquêteurs que l'ira n'est pas à
l'origine de cet attentat tue tennis la
france carrément éliminé au premier tour
de la fed cup par la russie 3 2 cet
après midi à moscou que celle bertrand
première surprise amélie mauresmo joue
en double à la place d'alexandre à
s'user
deuxième surprise ce n'est pas nathalie
tauziat une des meilleures joueuses du
monde de la spécialité qui tient équipe
mais amélie mauresmo
ça n'empêche pas d'y forger des
trinquets les françaises ont perdu le
premier set 6 0
makarova hip hop ceva ont pris de
vitesse les deux françaises peu à peu
mauresmo et aux ja remontent à la
surface la deuxième manche est plus
accroché mais le tie break n'a pas suffi
troisième et dernière surprise la france
pas de rythme pour cause il ya dix jours
avec et des jours sans
j'ai pas bien joué ce week-end voit la
sarre et j'avais le canadien d'autres
ossements bien énorme déception pour
l'équipe de france qui s'est fait battre
par les russes qui jouait sans
kournikova la meilleure joueuse de
l'équipe
le très beau roman de frison roche
premier de cordée a été adapté pour la
télévision et c'est à partir de demain
soir que france 2 diffusera ce téléfilm
dans la réalisation constitue en soi un
véritable défi puisque les équipes ont
travaillé en haute montagne dominique
barrau la corde est trop courte
en dessous le vide pas fait passion et
fuit son amour et mort avec la montagne
comme actrice principale
dans cette adaptation à la télé de la
célèbre trilogie de frison roche
on est sur place accrochée au piton avec
toute l'équipe
le pari était osé une seule fois il y à
plus d'un demi siècle le cinéma avait
réalisé premier de cordée mais jamais on
avait monté caméra et acteurs jusqu'à
4000 mètres comme aujourd'hui je prends
pas de référence par rapport à ce film
ce qui se passe c'est que en 43e il
avait le temps de faire les choses
alors que maintenant nous on a des
moyens techniques
rapide comme l'hélicoptère ses moyens
coûtent cher donc on a une pression par
rapport au rendement que eux n'avaient
pas à l'époque
pour y arriver la production a utilisé
deux réalisateurs l'un pour les plateaux
l'autre pour les scènes d escalade
malgré tout danger ici la chute d'un
paquet de neige a failli emporter la
lumière
premier de cordée c'est une histoire
d'amour qui a mobilisé 20 guides pour
trente acteurs et 500 figurants et
surtout la montagne la seule qui ne
respectent jamais le scénario
cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
sur les écrans d'un film réalisé par
chris menges de l'asean avec nastassja
kinski marianne denicourt et daniel
auteuil que j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
entre fiction et documentaire un film
qui dénonce les réseaux de pédophilie
daniel auteuil joue le rôle d'annoncer
n'officie des stups exil à londres qui
devient détective privé une sorte de
entier roues un rôle joué en anglais je
vous propose tout de suite un extrait
soit
accenture
obsèques ce vrai
pour dîner spectacle
bonsoir
est-ce qu'il faut avoir de la colère de
la d'initiation pour entrer pour
accepter un rôle comme celui ci rentrer
dans ce jeu vous laissé par la colère de
christian gay ce que j'ai pu j'ai pu
raconter faire ce film si vous voulez ça
ne c'est une histoire qu'il ne pouvait
pas se raconter sans sans ce genre de
metteur en scène comme ken loach ou
makli c'est à dire ce metteur en scène
qui avait fait un monde à part et où
elle est déjà à l'époque dénoncé
l'apartheid
c'est à dire que ces types qui sont
capables à la fois avec une grande
pudeur de de pouvoir faire éclater cette
violence-là quoi c'est bien sûr que
forcément forcément 7,7 coller à cette
violence nous a tous nous avons tous été
enrobées pas cette violence là et que ce
film et est sûrement le film plus
violent que j'aie jamais eu à faire
jusqu'à présent
en effet et diriez vous que c'est un
film presque militant est en tout cas
que cette enfance maltraitée violenté a
une résonance résonance en vous oui
c'est un film militant au sens large
c'est vrai que moi je suis je suis
touché par mais pas que par ça je veux
dire par là que je l'enfance blé blé
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui me
touche c'est aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'avais fait le huitième jour
mais si vous voulez je ne suis qu'un
acteur donc je ne peux madinier que que
par le talent des auteurs alors allongé
en profitent comme ça sans nous ils ont
nom et vous en avez aussi
merci beaucoup il s'emparait de la
deuxième fille leur crime avec vanessa
paradis là que j'ai énormément aimé ce
film a parfois les allures d'un
reportage d'un documentaire je pense que
c'est pour ajouter à l'authenticité
vous pensez que c'est une façon aussi de
vous montrer qu'il n'y a pas de
banalisation pas d'indifférence pas de
mise en scène sur sur la misère lui si
c'est assez 7,7
si vous voulez il faille il était
impératif que que ces scènes
ces scènes d'une grande violence qui
sont les convois les enfants maltraités
de ça il fallait que qu'il n'y ait pas
de complaisance et le fils effectivement
est toujours comme ça on ne sait pas une
fiction troupes américaines trop
lourdingue
aurait on était dérangeante pour moi
j'aurais pas accepter de se finir comme
ça alors que là le fait qu'on soit
toujours on se perd nous on se perd
entre la fiction de cette espèce de
reportage alors c'est la première fois
que vous jouez en anglais mais on peut
voir le film en français aussi rassurez
vous il a beaucoup de valeur en anglais
j'ai envie de vous demander s'il ya une
sonorité forcément différente une autre
façon de montrer ses intentions de
pousser ses silences de de jouer avec
les mots et que c'était un défi à
chalenge à un jeu un handicap terrible c
était un peu tout ça l'accent français
il en avait coûté je suis français je
joue en france et je me suis beaucoup
donné beaucoup de mal vous savez pour
garder cet accent français
non mais je n'en doute pas je suis dur
de travailler dans ma soeur d'aya en
anglais c'est dur c'est dur oui c'est là
que l'aîné ou nous c'est humainement
c'est à dire que les premiers quinze
jours moi je n'avais jamais fait ça donc
je me dis comment joue ton en tant qu en
anglais j'en sais rien j'avais bien des
camarades qui m'avait dit c'est facile
vas-y mais c'est pas si évident que ça
et puis en fait au bout d'une quinzaine
de jours
jouer que ce soit en anglais en espagnol
s'est toujours passé joué que si vous
voulez ce qui compte c'est les émotions
et puis c'est pas un film tellement qui
axé sur la parole c'est un film qui est
axé sur le sur l'action alors j'ai envie
un peu de parler de vous de votre jeu
d'acteur je trouve que ces derniers
temps vous êtes vous avez acquis une
force une puissance extraordinaire et
notamment dans ce film de patrice
leconte a une fille sur le pont
est-ce que vous avez l'impression d'être
toujours en pleine évolution est ce que
c'est un compliment pour vous quand vous
dites que vous êtes meilleur et que vous
êtes en évolution oui oui je pourrais je
préfère qu'on dise que je suis meilleur
et d'évolution que moyen non non ce que
bien comme d'habitude
bref voilà notre site c'est très
agréable non effectivement c'est à dire
que c'est vrai que le jour où je
m'arrêterai de de chercher je ne sommes
pas dire que j'aurais trouvé ça veut
dire que je commence à m'ennuyer quoi
donc c'est vrai que j'aime toujours j'ai
cette curiosité d'aller vers des rôles
différents et essayer d'avancer
vous êtes vous avez besoin de vous
mettre en danger ces derniers sont en
danger
disons de me mettre en mouvement quoi
merci en tout cas de 10 l'état et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
c'est la fin de ce journal vous en
rappelle les principaux titres
arrivé à lyon cet après midi des
premiers réfugiés venant de macédoine
deux autres avions dont l'un devrait
atterrir dans les minutes qui viennent
fonte donc intérêt dans cette soirée
au total 308 albanais prise en charge
d'abord dans des foyers d'accueil
et puis en macédoine en albanie le flot
des réfugiés continue de prendre de
l'ampleur
trente cinq mille nouveaux arrivants
sont attendus dans les jours qui
viennent à la frontière avec l'albanie
après la démission de philippe séguin
les ténors de la droite appelle à une
liste d'union et ample de la main au
centre françois bayrou fait ce soir une
réponse en demi teinte dans un instant
la météo isabelle martinez 29 55 sens
unique avec kevin costner 12h45 le
dernier journal lance du prime à 7h50
dans les 4 vérités françaises abordent
recevra le député udf renault de neuilly
du fab de ma 20h vous retrouverez claude
sérillon ce je vous remercie notre
attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2